having some practical suggestions which  we give on a handout that parents can  turn to when they have those fussy times  with their baby can really help them  stay calm in that moment the 5s is our  techniques that we talk about a lot so  one is good swaddling technique one is  shushing because that makes like a white  noise type of a sound one is laying them  on their side or their stomach certainly  not for sleep but just while they're  crying sometimes that can really relieve  tummy pain for babies who are gassy when  it's swinging making that swinging  motion and then one is sucking whether  it's on a pacifier or nursing this baby  isn't crying because the baby doesn't  like them it's just what babies do